TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
LinkedIn uses Android Studio
to build high quality Android
apps.
To hear their protips, visit
the link for the video.
Guetzli is a new
open source algorithm
that creates high quality JPEG
images with file sizes 35%
smaller than currently
available methods.
A link to the GitHub
is on the post.
The WebGL JavaScript
API exposes hardware
accelerated 3D
graphics to the web.
Chrome 56 brings support for
WebGL 2.0, a major upgrade
to the API, which unlocks
a variety of new graphics
features and advanced
rendering techniques.
To get started with WebGL 2.0,
check out the WebGL 2.0 samples
pack linked from the post.
We are releasing a major
upgrade to SyntaxNet.
It incorporates nearly a
year's worth of our research
on multilingual
language understanding
and is available to anyone
interested in building systems
for processing and
understanding text.
To learn more about SyntaxNet
or a new multilingual parsing
competition, check out the post.
Science isn't just about
discovering new results.
It's also about
human understanding.
That's why, in collaboration
with OpenAI, DeepMind,
YC Research and others,
we're excited to announce
the launch of Distill, a
new open source science
journal and ecosystem supporting
human understanding of machine
learning.
Distill is an
independent organization
dedicated to fostering a
new segment of the research
community.
Follow the link to
see the overview page
or read the latest articles.
You can now get
insights into how
your Firebase realtime
database instance is
performing by using the profiler
built into the Firebase CLI.
That means you can now easily
monitor your database writes
and reads at the path level,
collecting granular data
on bandwidth usage and speed.
Screenshots are on the post.
In the past few weeks,
AdMob has rolled out
support for video assets
in Native Ads Express,
giving you a new way to create
more engaging presentations
for your users.
Code and a video
are on the post.
If you like the Dev Show, please
share it with your friends
and colleagues.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching
the Dev Show.
Once you're done sharing it with
your friends and colleagues,
check out some of our previous
episodes here or subscribe.
See you next time.